From cold-blooded murder to toxic
mind games, Yellowstone has it all,
but it's complicated. So grab
your cowboy hat and get ready,
because we're taking a look at the
Yellowstone scenes that didn't age well.
In the Season 2 episode "Resurrection
Day," the level of violence we've become
accustomed to on Yellowstone rises to a new
level. As the only daughter of the Duttons,
Beth is known for her bold personality,
which usually takes the form of fiery comebacks
and an abrasive attitude. It's almost a surprise,
then, when she's attacked at her office. As
Rip desperately tries to reach Beth before
it's too late, two masked men sent by Malcolm
Beck storm the premises, hoping to scare her.
"All that tough talk, Beth.
I've got the cure for that. We'll see how
tough you are after I give it to you."
What's most notable about this scene is just how
violent it is. A fearful Beth is left bloodied
and vulnerable in the grip of both men. That's
not to say she doesn't fight back. She tries to
gouge their eyes out and throws them through
glass walls. The fight is a testament to the
fact that Yellowstone is willing to "go there" —
but also that it can take its grittiness too far.
What's more, it doesn't send a great message
about violence against women. Although it's
commendable to show what can actually happen so
explicitly, it's also a straight-up brutal watch.
The most heartbreaking moment
comes when Beth lets herself cry,
the tough, gritty exterior she's spent a
lifetime building up temporarily broken.
There are few people who inspire more fear
on the ranch than Lloyd Pierce. He might
even outstrip the infamously brutal Rip
Wheeler in this department. In the Season
4 episode "Winning or Learning," the stage
is set for an incredibly questionable brawl,
with Rip setting Lloyd against Walker.
While Lloyd maintains the upper hand,
the pair go for round two a few episodes
later, with Lloyd beating Walker to a pulp
in the middle of the ranch. To teach Lloyd
a lesson, Rip smashes his hand with a boot.
Though it's unsurprising to see a
Yellowstone brawl in such gory detail,
it doesn't age well within the big picture
of Rip's character development. His violent
outburst is his own fault — something he quickly
seems to realize as he leaves Lloyd bleeding.
"There's no fighting on this
ranch. You want to fight somebody,
you come fight me. I'll fight you all f—in' day."
Beyond the brutality lies the question of
whether or not this lesson is necessary,
or if Rip overdid it. Even though the fight
sets Rip up for a juicy redemption arc,
it does a disservice to the storylines
and relationship that come before it.
Though uncomfortable scenes
often contain great messages,
that doesn't make them any easier to watch. In
the Season 3 episode "I Killed A Man Today,"
Monica finds herself in trouble after
catching a ride with a known predator.
After trying to persuade her to leave
the vehicle to get better phone service,
he becomes violent and forcefully restrains her on
the ground. But Monica has put herself in the line
of fire in the name of a sting. A sniper swiftly
brings the predator to his arguably deserved end.
While it's admirable for Yellowstone to take on
the issue of violence against Indigenous women,
the scene has some questionable side effects.
Simply put, it's terrible to watch. And the
scene reinforces the idea that women need
to relive their trauma for the sake of
the greater good. Monica is visibly shaken
by what she's gone through. She's strong,
but even the most rock-solid person would be
rattled by such an encounter. Opening up emotional
wounds is commonplace on Yellowstone, but it
could, perhaps, be handled more sensitively.
As far as the Yellowstone universe goes, Sheriff
Donnie Haskell wasn't a major player. Throughout
the first four seasons, his questionable morals
and alliance with the Dutton family often fade
into the background. That being said, his
sudden death takes viewers by surprise and
leads to moments that are excruciating to watch.
In "No Kindness for the Coward," John and Rip get
involved in a diner hold-up. Mid-robbery, John
storms in from the back kitchen to try and take
out the thieves, and Donnie gets caught in the
crossfire, taking a fatal blow to the throat.
To make matters worse, Donnie tries to call his
daughter, only managing to get a few words out
before he dies. John is left to tell Donnie's
daughter what's happened. The final moments of
the scene are incredibly intense and especially
hard to watch for anyone who's suddenly lost a
loved one. And afterward, audiences are left with
the knowledge that Donnie's death could have been
prevented if John and Rip hadn't gotten involved.
Is the scene just a case of someone playing
the hero for their own reasons? If so, that's
seriously — perhaps unnecessarily — wrenching.
Like the Montagues and Capulets of Romeo
and Juliet, the ongoing war between the
Duttons and Becks is neverending. It's
also a lynchpin of the Yellowstone story.
"I'm not gonna lose this one, Rip. Not this one."
By the time fans get to Season 2's "Sins of
the Father," the feud is well established.
Many of the Becks have met a grisly end
at the hands of the Duttons, but no death
is more unnecessary or confusing than Teal's
sudden demise. As Kayce sneaks into his house,
he finds an unsuspecting Teal on the toilet
and shoots him. As Kayce watches him die,
he tells Teal he promised his wife to kill
him in the most humiliating way possible.
As far as humiliation goes, the scene
hits the nail on the head. The whole
sequence is awkward and excruciating to
watch, not to mention fairly irrelevant
to the bigger story. There's no doubt
Teal brought this misery on himself,
but couldn't he die with dignity intact?
Somewhere between funny and hard-hitting,
the scene finds itself in an emotional no man's
land that leaves viewers confused and embarrassed.
Sibling rivalry is at the heart of any good
family drama, but the tension between Beth and
Jamie is unique. The intensity of their hatred
is palpable from the very first episode, but
the reason behind it isn't revealed in Season 3's
"Cowboys and Dreamers." In a flashback sequence,
teenage Beth confides in Jamie that she
needs to hide a pregnancy. Jamie takes
her out of town for an abortion, but neglects
to mention that it will leave her infertile.
"You don't want to do this here.
A requirement for patients receiving an
abortion at this clinic is sterilization."
It goes without saying that exploring pregnancy
and abortion on TV is going to be contentious.
Regardless, in the eyes of many viewers, this
scene takes things too far. Some fans find the
storyline outright insulting, while some medical
professionals take issue with its inaccuracy.
It doesn't take long for Yellowstone to establish
exactly what kind of show it is. In the opening
moments of the pilot, audiences are introduced to
John Dutton, currently in the middle of trying to
protect his ranch from land developers. A stream
of blood runs down John's face as he tries to
comfort a suffering horse, then puts it out of its
misery. We later learn that it's all a result of a
nasty traffic accident. There's something about
seeing an animal suffer that hits extra hard.
"The things we lose to keep you fed."
Yellowstone's stars have had to clarify
that the show doesn't abuse animals,
but PETA has actively encouraged viewers
to boycott the show. For some viewers,
the opening scene is a questionable
introduction to the series as a whole.
When it comes to Rip's wrath
on Yellowstone, no one is safe.
Characters take their well-being into their own
hands when they decide to cross the Dutton family,
and Season 3's "Meaner Than Evil" shows
just how terrible the consequences can be.
"That son of a b—h has something
belongs to me and I want it back."
As a major antagonist across multiple seasons,
Wade Morrow quickly loses the respect of the
family — especially once he's accused of stealing.
After betraying the Duttons and their ranch,
Wade is tracked down by Rip and murdered in
the middle of nowhere. As a branded worker,
Wade also has his brand cut
off before his body is dumped.
Yellowstone routinely pushes the boundaries
for what can be shown on cable TV,
but this scene might just take the
biscuit. Viewers without the stomach
for gore will definitely need to look
away, as close-ups of the brand removal,
paired with Wade's painful cries and the
knife sound effects, are a lot to take.
"Mister, I don't know you, but
if you're wearing that brand,
you must be a bad man. These motherf—ers
want it back, you must be even worse."
Even though the series is set in the present day,
the violence feels uncomfortably old-fashioned,
bordering on barbaric. As arguably the
most agonizing death in Yellowstone so
far, this scene is one of the
show's most shocking moments.
In Season 2's "Blood the Boy," after Jamie tries
to recant his statement while cooperating with
Sarah's campaign to expose corruption on the
Dutton ranch, the two find themselves alone.
"You're not the first source to have second
thoughts, but we're way past that point."
Things quickly get ugly. Sarah tells him that his
family deserves to lose everything, and Jamie is
enraged. In a fury, he smashes Sarah's head into
the roof of their nearby car. As if that wasn't
bad enough, he finishes the job off by strangling
Sarah as she lies helplessly on the ground.
Although it goes without saying
that Sarah doesn't deserve to die,
the way Jamie goes about killing her makes the
situation even worse. With a chilling stare,
Jamie leans into his dark side with no
hesitation. "I'm so sorry," he repeats,
as he strangles Sarah — but does that
matter? In fact, the dialogue makes
it even more uncomfortable to watch. No matter
what he's saying, Jamie commits a horrific act.
By the time viewers get to Season 3, there's just
one catastrophe missing from the Duttons' lives:
a life-threatening explosion. The episode "The
World Is Purple" delivers that missing link,
with Beth's assistant losing her life by opening
a package that also sets Beth's office ablaze. The
hit on the Dutton family doesn't stop there.
Kayce narrowly escapes being gunned down,
while John is nearly the victim of a drive-by
shooting. It's incredible that any family members
survive the episode, let alone all of them.
But while the action might seem far-fetched,
it's the gratuitous deaths that
call this scene into question.
In the case of Beth's office, it doesn't make
much sense for her assistant to be killed off.
Not only does her loss seem completely
unnecessary, it also puts the spotlight
back on the show's tendency to depict extreme
violence against women. If the creators wanted
this episode to have maximum impact, surely
a Dutton needed to be lost along the way?
Context tells us everything, and when it comes
to the Dutton family, a lot needs to be unpacked
in order to understand their dysfunctional
relationships. A hefty chunk of Yellowstone
Season 5 is devoted to digging into the family's
history, with the episode "The Dream Is Not Me"
focusing on John Dutton's rise to the top. While
John doesn't really change throughout the series,
we learn how his toxic personality has infected
Rip, who has never been able to lie to him.
Teenage Rip was at odds with a boy called Rowdy
over Beth around the same time. He knocks Rowdy
to the ground with a boulder — truly copying
the behavior he's grown up around all his life.
In essence, this is a masterclass in
how to be a terrible person. Though
Yellowstone features plenty
of rough-and-tumble guys,
toxic masculinity is likely not a
character choice that's going to age well.
"I feel like I shouldn't be
watching but I can't stop."
"It's riveting."
Not only do viewers see Rip forced to make a
choice that could have easily been avoided,
but John is also complicit because he
gave Rip the brand that set him on a
path of no return. Though the relationship
between the pair is undoubtedly interesting,
Rip's choice to murder Rowdy, and the way he does
it, is perhaps an unnecessary addition to the
problems that are already woven into the show.